lp elle continue avec le match des idées
confrontation de points de vue ce soir
entre jean pierre mignard et paul cassia
on va s'arrêter sur une autre polémique
qui monte ce françois patriat ça ne va
pas vous plaire des propos et qu'ils ont
là aussi créé la surprise ce sont ceux
de frédéric vidal elle dénonce je cite
l'islamo gauchisme qui gangrènent
l'université est plus que ça elle lance
une enquête au cnrs la ministre mettait
le doigt sur un phénomène réel et
inquiétant
pourquoi cette sémantique elle même
assez connoté entend ouvrir la
discussion avec nos invités juste après
le rappel des faits et les réactions
avec baptiste lépinay hier à l'assemblée
nationale la ministre de l'enseignement
supérieur frédéric vidal a confirmé sa
volonté de mettre en place une enquête
sur l'islamo gauchisme à l'université
j'ai été interrogé effectivement sur ce
que l'on voit apparaître dans les
universités à savoir des universitaires
qui se disent eux même empêché par
d'autres empêché de mener leurs
recherches empêché de mener leur étude
et oui je vais demander effectivement à
ce que l'on fasse un bilan de l'ensemble
des recherches qui se déroule dans notre
pays
une proposition saluée par cette
sénatrice les républicains que la mini
zeleny verser le prenne à bras le corps
est en tout cas demande à ce qu'on
regarde ce qui se passe vraiment les
dents les inégalités c'est une très très
bien mais je pense que l'université est
un lieu d'ouverture d'esprit de
contestation aussi au sens intellectuel
du terme et que malheureusement dans
certaines universités on ne peut plus
tout dire il ne peut plus presque penser
un peu différemment que la pensée unique
le sénateur communiste et ancien
chercheur pierre ouzoulias ce point
qu'une diversion et appellent au départ
de la ministre je crois que la ministre
est incapable de répondre au malaise
étudiants donc elle ouvre un contre-feu
avec les allumettes du front national
c'est catastrophique
elle doit rester en poste la ministre ce
sont ces le problème c'est celui de sa
conscience avec elle même moi je
l'inciterai à
à partir si je crois qu'elle a plus rien
à faire à la tête du ministère de la
connaissance de son côté la conférence
des présidents d'université a fait part
de sa stupeur dans un communiqué
l'islamo gauchisme n'est pas un concept
c'est une pseudo notion dont on
chercherait en vain un commencement de
définition scientifique et qu'il
conviendrait de l'essai sinon aux
animateurs de ces news plus largement à
l'extrême droite qui l'a popularisé
autre problématique
impossible pour le cnrs d'enquêter sur
les travaux des professeurs car leur
liberté académique est défendue par la
constitution avec nous pour ce match des
idées ce soir jean pierre mignard
bienvenue avocat au barreau de paris co
fondateur du think tank politique de la
terre et paul cassia bienvenue à vous
également vous êtes professeur de droit
public auteur de deux livres la
république en miettes et la république
du futur je vous donne tout de suite le
communiqué du cnrs qui a donc réagi ce
soit cette polémique et je le cite ce
communiqué l'islamo gauchisme slogans
politiques utiliser dans le débat public
ne correspond à aucune réalité
scientifique et le cnrs condamne avec
fermeté
celles et ceux qui tentent d'en profiter
pour remettre en cause la liberté
académique réaction donc très forte ce
soir du cnrs à juste titre paul cassia
évidemment c'est un immense camouflet
pour la ministre de l'enseignement
supérieur et de la recherche
comme je crois il n'a jamais eu dans ce
domaine il ya au départ un paradoxe très
fort plusieurs paradoxes dans cette
affaire est le premier c'est que la
ministre de l'enseignement supérieur et
de la recherche qui est chargé de
promouvoir seul enseignement supérieur
recherche et universités les
établissements du supérieur fait le
contraire de ce que doit être sa mission
c'est à dire qu'elle les dévalorise elle
laisse croire qu'il y à des courants qui
sont extrémistes qui sont tendancieux
dans une université elle n'y
pratiquement l'existence des libertés
académiques le contrôle par les pairs et
pire encore elle dresse les
universitaires les uns contre les autres
le cnrs contre les universités des
collègues qui sont chargés de vérifier
les recherches
de certains de leurs autres collègues
donc qu'elle lançait une enquête à lens
il m'a d'ailleurs elle lance une enquête
et cette enquête elle est lancée sur
deux postulats qui sont content effarant
là c'est qu'il y aurait des courants
dits islamo gauchiste à l'université
personne ne sait ce que c'est je suis
dans une université qui a pourtant
beaucoup de de punch comme ce qui a une
histoire paris 1 panthéon sorbonne je ne
suis pas sûr d'avoir rencontré sauf à
mon insu un ou une islamo gauchiste donc
il ya déjà là un concept qui était un
peu fumeux le cnrs la dénoncer à juste
titre et elle le fait par ailleurs en
indiquant hier à l'assemblée nationale
que sa volonté de lancer cette enquête
administrative a été déclenchée par la
vision des images au capitole d'un
manifestant qui est porté un grave aux
confédérés et là on a vraiment du mal on
va débattre avec jean pierre mignard
mais on va du mal on va avoir du mal à
rester sérieux c'est si c'est vraiment
la cause du déclenchement elle et je
veux dire c'est une bouffonnerie on il
n'y a pas d'autre mot jean pierre
mignard
oui je vais moi aussi je suis archi dont
on ait trouvé des chercheurs dont je
suis aussi docteur de planter en
sorbonne ce que je veux dire c'est que
c'est d'abord le rôle du ministre mais
il va cesser de défendre universitaire
si il ya eu un rapport parlementaire qui
était un peu accusatoire elle devait
défendre l'université du rôle que jouent
les mercis est un pays l'ensemble des
travaux qui étaient à compliquer en
université elle défend et elle dit
ensuite s'il vend tellement il ya un
problème je lancerai une inspection elle
doit d'abord défenseur des universités
c'est ça premiers mois ne le fait pas
deuxièmement on ne sait pas du tout ce
que c'est en effet que cette histoire
d'islam au gauchisme ça il faudrait
quand même qu'on sache un peu de quoi il
en est je souhaite bien du courage à
cette inspection pour chercher cette
cette chose pour l'instant indéfinie des
études ya des études qui sont faits qui
vont sernin d'hygiénisme le des
colonials intersectionnelle it et c'est
pas très nouveau que c'est aux états
unis les universités sont son travail
constamment sur ce genre de choses ça eh
bien parce que la question indienne la
question noire
dans toujours c'est tour est à
l'évidence on voit bien que dans notre
pays
ces questions là commence à se poser qui
est des travaux de recherche
bien sûr j'espère bien qu'ils aient des
travaux de recherche et ya rien de
scandaleux par exemple sur
l'intersexualité je vois très bien ce
que c'est je rien de scandaleux donc
j'ai l'impression que vous savez en 68
c'était la même chose au ces la faculté
de vincennes c'est la sociologie je me
souviens juste aux gamins cca sociologie
comme si la sociologie et lever les
barricades quand le gardien atteinte
c'est aberrant il sait des réflexes très
conservateur et un peu ignorant ce qui
est d'ailleurs peu inquiétant de la part
d'une ministre bon alors et puis deux
troisièmes en échangeant termine si la
situation de l'université est ce qu'elle
est où on en est jusqu'à lancer des
inspections cette nature puis j'ai vu
d'ailleurs une tribune d'intellectuels
d'ailleurs vous à tutelle estimable
présentait universités sous un tel jour
et dans ce cas là il faut fermer les
universités il faut dissoudre
l'université et dans ces conditions je
pense que madame vidal s'il se prend en
effet ce type de de camoufler le
président de la république devrait lui
dire non désolé vais veiller à ce que ça
fonctionne bien mais enfin il faut
défendre l'université française vous
imaginez à l'extérieur ce que ça
signifie parce que pareil partout
nous faisons des travaux de recherche
universités offrent effectivement les
moyens de faire des recherches dit
qu'elle qu'elle notoriété on donne à
l'université ce n'est pas à la hauteur
on n y avait pas au niveau
d'ailleurs le sénateur socialiste
ouzoulias cela dit tout à l'heure sur
notre antenne ils l'appellent à
démissionner tout de même c'est pas la
première fois qu'un ministre de ce
gouvernement emploie ces mots évoquent
cette question dit d'islam au gauchisme
à l'université c'était en octobre
dernier jean michel blanquer air qui
avait jeté un pavé dans la mare gossip
et il avait dit ce qu'on appelle
l'islamo gauchisme fait des ravages
il avait cité plusieurs endroits
plusieurs secteurs où l'islamo gauchisme
faisait des ravages et il avait cité
l'université
des ravages à l'université que veut-il
dire est ce que il y a si on ouvre un
peu les yeux de l'idéologie dans les
universités giros c'est possible bon
c'est normal qu'ils aient de l'idéologie
dans les universités moi même j'ai rangé
comme jean pierre mignard j'espère c'est
un jeu suit traversée par certains
courants de pensée mais de là à raconter
n'importe quoi comme le fait jean michel
blanquer fondée sur rien a ajouté
jean-michel lancker c'est mon collègue
il est professeur de droit public
je peux vous assurer qu'il n'y a pas de
ravages islamo gauchiste à université
paris 1 panthéon sorbonne où pourtant
comme l'a indiqué jean pierre mignard il
ya des collègues qui travaillent sur le
genre il ya des collègues qui
travaillent sur la race je n'ai jamais
rencontré islamo gauchiste alors
peut-être qu'il ce qu'il se cache qu'il
se rassure qu'il le faut vous faire à
vous faire de la politique parce qu'on
est à un an d'une présidentielle parce
que ça fait bien d'en parler c'est très
certainement qu'il y a de cela c'est il
ya trente ans on parlait de la
filtration judéo veulent chez vicky à
l'université alors maintenant celle
islamo gauchiste je n'aime pas tout ça
je n'aime pas ses mots je n'aime pas ces
facilités de langage
surtout quand aux fins de l'université
où par définition
l'intelligence la recherche est
peut-être un peu quelquefois la nuance
devrait être au premier rang je rejoins
ce que dit jean pierre mignard et je
voudrais ajouter que la chasse aux
sorcières qu'a initié la ministre
frédéric vidal n'est pas tout à fait
nouvelle je crois que ce gouvernement
cet exécutif déteste les contre-pouvoirs
qu'ils soient institutionnels citoyens
ou académique ce que ça m'a rappelé ce
sont les enquêtes de police qui ont été
diligentées contre certains journalistes
pour connaître leurs sources
ça me rappelait aussi la polémique qui
avait eu lieu sur le parquet national
financiers et l' enquête diligentée par
le garde des sceaux par des juges contre
d'autres juges et là on dresse des
universitaires contre d'autres
universitaires c'est c'est très
inquiétant c'est le reflet d'une
démocratie qui devient de plus en plus
il libérera là mon sens elle est
deuxième thème de ce match messieurs c
l'idée d'expérimenter des zones sans
contrôle d'identité vous le savez elle a
été proposée par la défenseure des
droits clairet donc il mettre fin à ce
qu'elle appelle donc des contrôles
d'identité discriminatoires
ça fait hurler une bonne partie de la
classe politique surtout de droite et
notamment vous karl olive qui nous
rejoignent et dans ce match des idées
bonsoir et merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation vous êtes maire divers droite
de poissy vice président du conseil
départemental des yvelines avant de vous
donner la parole je voudrais juste qu'on
écoute la déclaration ferme sans
ambiguïté tout à l'heure au sénat de
jean castex sur ce dossier jeudi sur
l'année lé mans devant le sénat et
devant le pays qu'il n'y a pas et qu'il
n'y aura pas de zone sans contrôle
d'identité en application des lois de la
république
karl olive est ce que vous êtes rassuré
ce soir en entendant le premier ministre
écoutez comme d'habitude je me satisfait
évidemment d'un de ceux de ce pas en
arrière
après un pas en avant mais quel dommage
que ce pas en arrière et pas été fait
avant six à la minute où on a cette
proposition sur la table du premier
ministre du président de république et
je dois vous le dire c'est ce que j'ai
dit au président de république
on prend son téléphone et on vient
tester un petit peu cette idée sur le
terrain à gauche comme à droite et bien
on a des impôts doucement que je viens
d'entendre lycée à l'assemblée est
certainement au sénat mais ce que je
peux vous dire c'est que ça fait mal ça
fait mal et ce qui s'est passé
malheureusement à poissy ce week-end en
tout cas je dirais la triste promotion
qu'on envoie depuis 72 heures c'est bien
justement parce que ce défenseur des
droits géré seulement rien contre mana
bidon évidemment mais nous a fait une
espèce de concours lépine de la
bestialité or seuls pour mettre en
colère les policiers pour faire grand
sourire les jeunes dans les quartiers et
ce matin j'avais des jeunes dans les
quartiers en faisant formidable on va
plus rare contrôle dans le quartier
et puis pour mettre à mal le travail de
terrain des élus encore une fois mr de
france de toutes obédiences confondues
il n'y avait pas mieux moi j'en pâtit
aujourd'hui je peux vous garantir alors
évidemment
que c'est pas à cause de notre défenseur
des droits qui a eu ces incidents et ce
week-end mais la conséquence de la
promotion virale de la vidéo par les
policiers alors qu'habituellement il
sort sur un droit de réserve
c'est évidemment une conséquence directe
à cette provocation il n'y a pas d'autre
mot du défenseur des droits car le livre
est en train d'intervenir dans un match
des idées juridique alors j'aime faire
l'avocate de madame et dont est ce que
la défenseure des droits n'aura pas eu
au moins le mérite de poser un vrai
sujet sur la table puisque je vous
rappelle les chiffres de 2010 est de son
prédécesseur jacques toubon un jeune
homme perçu comme noir ou arabe a une
probabilité 20 fois plus élevé d'être
contrôlés que l'ensemble du reste de la
population
est-ce que tout de même ces chiffres ne
doivent pas nous pousser et vous ai
compris à nous interroger sur ce qu'il
faut faire ou pas sur ce problème de
contrôle au faciès
chère madame est-ce que vous pas une
seule seconde quand on a attendu d'avoir
une telle préconisations du défenseur
des droits pour agir dans nos quartiers
c'est bien méconnaître est ce qui se
passe sur le terrain
pardon de le dire à quoi si on a été
réélu à 75% dès le premier tour
je suis un homme de génération terrain
je suis né ici dans un quartier
populaire jeu c'est particulièrement
comment ça se passe le sujet c'est qu'on
doit dans un contrat gagnant-gagnant et
que les règles doivent être les mêmes
pour tous dont connu par tous
une fois tout le monde connaît les
règles vous êtes dans le jeu vous êtes
en dehors du jeu et quand il ya une
bêtise quand il ya une bavure policière
il faut le dire et il faut la condamner
c'est ce que je fais mais pour une
bavure policière on a combien d'actes
d'incivilité par semaine parfois dans
nos dans nos territoires
cela aussi je pense que il ya
effectivement un défenseur de droits qui
dans sa posture
moi j'aimerais bien aussi de temps en
temps on est un petit peu un défenseur
des devoirs parce que bien souvent il ya
c'est très strict pour citer en soit ces
droits et des devoirs est tout
simplement très déséquilibré son terrain
alors un petit mot peut-être sur ce que
vous faites sur le terrain puisque vous
nous parler du terrain qu'est ce que
vous faites contre le contrôle au faciès
te fait d'avoir c'est que je passe
beaucoup de temps sur sur le terrain
notamment dans dans les quartiers et je
vis dans ces quartiers la deuxième
chance si je ne fais aucune
stigmatisation et quand on prend des
décisions ici à la ville de poissy
les décisions sur les mêmes pour tous
quand on apporte du pouvoir d'achat pour
les
amis c'est les mêmes pour tous sans
aucune condition de ressources
et puis quand il ya un problème eh bien
on se déplace sur le terrain on va voir
ses problèmes hier il ya eu un problème
ce week-end qui est malheureusement pas
ja c'est presque un lieu commun alors
pas à poissy mais sur le territoire
actuellement je le disais on a une
délinquance des mineurs entre 12 et 17
ans qu on note de plus en plus avec des
jeunes qui refusent l'autorité
mais plutôt que de regarder à côté faut
aller les voir faut aller les voir et
pouvoir et les entendre et leur rappeler
que les règles et que la république ce
n'est pas de la provocation
un jour sur les policiers le lendemain
sur des ambulanciers ou des conflits
dans d'autres territoires
car le dis je vous propose de rester
avec nous puisque je vais faire réagir
nos invités en plateau jean pierre
mignard le 16 mars prochain sera examiné
au sénat la loi sécurité globale qui
propose notamment le récépissé les
caméras piétons notamment pour lutter
contre le contrôle au faciès est ce que
ce sont des meilleures pistes que celles
proposées par claire oui je comprends
d'avoir ce qu'on prend un peu l'émotion
du maire de poissy parce que c'est vrai
que la proposition de clairet dont ne
venait pas effectivement meilleur moment
pour pour poissy peut-être d'autres
endroits j'ai quand même précis éclairée
dont et c'est l'ancienne dirigeante daté
dé quart-monde la misère et le connaît
les quartiers elle connaît tes
clairement été créée par le père
brzezinski et par geneviève de gaulle
elle a été ma collègue au comité
national d'éthique dont je connais cette
femme admirable
je pense en effet peut-être n'at-elle
pas un sens politique parce que je pense
en effet que ce n'était pas le bon
moment ça je suis tout à fait d'accord
mais sur le fond et sur le fond il ya en
effet un problème d'ailleurs même la
chambre criminelle de la cour de
cassation l'a reconnu il ya en effet un
problème de deux contrôles au faciès moi
j'ai eu pendant trois ans un cabinet à
clichy sous bois
donc je connais bien et alors c'est pas
effectivement on fermait qu'ils soient
particuliers leur juste ajouter 2 le
seul d'ailleurs avoir un cabinet
d'avocats je voyais bien qu'il y avait
beaucoup de contrôles quelquefois des
contrôles répétés sur effectivement les
mêmes les mêmes garçons dont je dis pas
du tout que ce sont des anges monsieur
livre je vois bien mais il est exact que
cette répétition finissait par à
s'assimiler à du harcèlement et donc à
créer des rapports épouvantable entre
les jeunes et puis la police dont le
travail n'est pas facile je le sais bien
mais donc il y à une tentation
aujourd'hui de faire en sorte que hier
est récépissé c'est pas commode
le récépissé parce qu'il faut donner un
papier je fais un peu on m'avait
interrogé j'avais été auditionné sur ce
point c'est pas évident caméra oui
certainement je pense que c'est beaucoup
mieux
et enfin je pense quand même que pour ce
qui concerne les le corps des
fonctionnaires de police
je pense qu'il ya un travail éthique a
fermé à entre eux entre eux il faudrait
par exemple qu'il y est je vais proposer
cela dans la campagne de macron qu'il y
a dans chaque commissariat qu'il y ait
un fonctionnaire de police pas quelqu'un
d'extérieur ma faute je veux qu'il soit
un responsable éthique c'est à dire
qu'il y ait constamment du retour
d'expérience et une réflexion éthique
oui entre les fonctionnaires eux-mêmes
que les fonctionnaires de police créé
leur propre éthique pour effectivement
avancé et peut-être limité juguler ce
type de confrontation je pense que tu
vas bien falloir passer un moment donné
par ce type de choses on se parle et où
les fonctions de police se parlent entre
eux pas le cas tu tiens je partage pas
tout à fait ce qui vient d'être dit à la
fois par monsieur le maire et par jean
pierre mignard
c'est vrai que c'est difficile et je ne
chercherai pas à le faire de défendre
l'idée d' absence de contrôles
d'identité dans telle ou telle zone que
ce soit le 16e arrondissement de paris
où la ville de poissy
les contrôles doivent être exercées
d'une manière identique sur tout le
territoire c'est-à-dire à des conditions
restrictives qui sont posées par le code
de procédure pénale pas tout va pas un
contrôle au faciès un contrôle parce qu'
il peut y avoir à tel moment un risque
de trouble à l'ordre public
mais c'est vrai aussi ça a été relevé
par jean pierre mignard que bien c'est
contrôlé par vous même qui peuvent
peuvent dégénérer que certaines
personnes dans certains lieux peuvent
faire l'objet de contrôles qui sont plus
systématiques d'autres à titre personnel
j'en ai pratiquement je crois jamais été
contrôlée de toute ma vie on m'a jamais
demandé un jour malgré mes papiers dire
jamais donc je vais pas me plaindre d'un
excès de contrôle d'identité en revanche
peut-être qu'ailleurs peut-être que pour
certaines autres personnes il y à des
contrôles qui sont plus systématiques
qui peuvent devenir humiliant parce que
moi je vois des personnes contrôlées
dans le métro dans les rer
c'est vrai que c'est très humiliant il
ya des gens qui passent on regarde nous
demander un caisse d'identité voilà on
se dit mais qu'est ce qu'il a fait cela
qu'est ce qu'elle a fait celle là alors
la bonne solution c'est celle qui a
évoqué évidemment jean pierre mignard ce
sont les récépissés les caméras piétons
le cas échéant mais malheureusement ces
solutions
c'est un peu une tarte à la crème des
contrôles d'identité on en parle depuis
tellement d'années jean pierre mignard
l'a dit en 2010 est déjà pendant la
campagne précédente série savent a été
évoquée ce n'est toujours pas à l'heure
il ya peut-être des difficultés
techniques des difficultés
administratives mais je crois que c'est
une solution qui peut faire consensus et
qu'il est important d'essayer de mettre
enfin en application gens possible pour
répondre à la fois à paul cassia
monsieur olive que ne pas contrôler ne
signifie pas qu'ils aient pas de
policier est allé policiers patrouillent
simplement on contrôle pas et c'est ça
l'idée de la proposition gard et dont on
contrôle pas systématiquement et puis
d'ailleurs la loi est formelle la
procédure aussi en contrôle lorsque
peut-être des comportements sont
susceptibles effectivement d'annoncer la
commission d'une infraction mais elle
n'a jamais dit qu'il n'y aurait pas de
policier dire que les policiers
s'abstenait de pratiquer un contrôle
systématique qui pouvaient en effet
ensuite enclenché des ddd des conflits
un cc quand même peut-être pour nuancer
tout ça car le livre un dernier mot
peut-être avant de nous quitter oui deux
derniers mots si vous le voulez bien
encore merci pour votre avis test
partage ce partage évidemment la lecture
de modalités je crois que les caméras
portatives pour apporter beaucoup est-ce
qu'on systématise et à partir du 1er
juillet caméra portative au cros com de
com cela pour pour les falaises de la
police nationale notamment après si on
expérimente avec les policiers
municipaux depuis deux ans maintenant 28
k 2 extra sion 2 extraction de
l'extraction qui était malheureusement
sur une sur une preuve pas
malheureusement comme ça sur une preuve
de de léry notamment de deux mineurs
juste que je voulais juste revenir en
arrière pardonnez moi mais j'ai entendu
tout à l'heure le dossier sur liste
amoco schisme je voulais juste partage
avec vous le fait que j'ai passé
ma grande scolarité en université à
paris 8 saint denis dont on disait
qu'elle était plutôt une d'extrême
gauche etc
je rejoins vos invités jamais on ne m'a
parlé d'islam au gauchisme à paris 8 et
j'ai beaucoup apprécié la diversité la
richesse qu'on pouvait ressortir
notamment et c'est d'actualité sur la
lutte contre l'exclusion sociale
ce qui me permet aujourd'hui de la
conjuguer presque au quotidien ici à ici
à kouassi est comme ça c'est très clair
merci infiniment karl olive d'être
intervenue ce soir dans le match des
idées on va poursuivre mais sans vous on
va enchaîner sur deux autres thèmes
merci beaucoup en tout cas d'avoir été
notre invité troisième thème de ce match
messieurs ce vote par anticipation
voulue par le gouvernement lors de la
prochaine présidentielle un amendement
tombé du ciel ou plutôt de l'elysée nous
a dit bruno retailleau qui de fait passe
sous les radars du conseil d'état qui se
passe du travail approfondi du parlement
et qui pose aussi des questions
d'inégalité le patron de la majorité
sénatoriale se demande même si c'est
constitutionnel on l'écouté vous
répondez après ça créerait aussi une
rupture d'égalité entre par exemple des
ruraux qui sont à 70 soit une heure de
voyage de la ville qui ne pourraient pas
venir voter par exemple en milieu de
semaine à mercredi
et puis bale ceux qui sont tout près du
bureau de vote qui pourraient eux voté
je me demande même si c'est bien
constitutionnel donc toutes ces
questions d'ordre technique d'ordre
démocratique d'ordre juridique d'ordre
politique mérite un examen et ça ne peut
pas se faire à la va vite comme ça avec
un amendement qui vient brutalement à la
fin du parcours et de l'examen
parlementaire alors c'est toujours
difficile de répondre de manière
tranchée mais paul cassia ça vous
semblerait inconstitutionnelle ce vote
par anticipation qui créerait une
rupture d'égalité entre les ruraux et
les urbains en lui-même peut-être pas
dans les modalités qui sont contenus
dans l'amendement du gouvernement il ya
quand même une difficulté qui tient
c'est le deuxième alinéa de
l'explication donnée par le gouvernement
à son amendement qui tient à ce que la
liste des communes où se trouveraient
des machines à voter serait fixé par le
gouvernement
donc c'est un là un arrêté du ministre
de l'intérieur qui déciderait que dans
telle commune il aurait des machines à
voter mais dans tel autre il n'y en
aurait pas et c'est là où on peut venir
le risque de discrimination puisque des
machines à voter peuvent être installés
dans des communes qui sont plutôt
favorables à telle tendance est en
revanche ailleurs il n'y aurait pas de
machines à voter c'est de la manière
dont s'organise ray le vote par par
anticipation d'accord que peut venir la
difficulté saint pierre mignan l'ours
est exact puis à peut-être une autre
question qui est plus exactement le
niveau de renseignements ou
d'informations donc à l'électeur doit
posséder avant de voter parce que si on
vote 4 5 jours avant le jour fatidique
des hommes on perd beaucoup de choses à
dire et il se passe de l'ailé de les 24
48 heures qui s'est présenté à une
élection n'importe laquelle celle très
bien que les 48 ou 72 heures sont
souvent décisives pour faire un peu
bouger les lecteurs c'est toujours à ce
moment là que les candidats font des
coups s'est pas découvert d'effets
atypique est en tout cas fonds veulent
choqué veulent apprécier je suis d'une
campagne de françois mitterrand contre
eux c'était valéry giscard d'estaing
soit au général de boissieu et ses
jambes du général de gaulle qui était
grand chancelier de l'ordre national
honneur était venue dire solennellement
un déviant
je ne remettrai pas le cordon à françois
mitterrand c était juste un événement
quand même alors réponse du camp
socialiste c'était le l'amiral
sanguinetti dansante groupe uni fort de
major général en retraite de la marine
qui me dire tout ça c'est factieux s'est
il amusé il vient c'était intéressant
des deux officiers généraux et pas
n'importe lesquels ça s'est passé à deux
jours voyez donc il faut laisser aux
électeurs ou et je comprends très bien
ce que disent nos retailleau et paul
cassia mais faut laisser aux électeurs
le soi le goût d'aller jusqu'au bout et
jusqu'au bout il se passe quelque chose
même si c'était des gens qui ne comptait
pas voter parce qu'ils n'étaient pas là
le week-end de l'élection par exemple
sur ça c'est pas parce que c'est une
lutte entre l'abstention c'est ça c'est
un cas très particulier un simplement
jusqu'ici on a quand même essayé de
trouver des solutions des gens gens
votent
jusqu'ici ils ont voté ya pas eu de
problème il n'y a même pas eu d'ailleurs
surtout de la présidentielle à la
présidentielle les gens votent beaucoup
à deux présidentielles
pourquoi alors sélection américaine vu
qu'on rit beauté très longtemps par
avant donc il ya peut-être un mimétisme
un peu provincial si je peux me
permettre par rapport aux états unis
mais je suis pas sûr que ce soit bien
utile car on n'a pas enregistré de
problème particulier en france dans ce
domaine donc bon je pas le cas ces
raisons je peux pas forcément anti
constitutionnelle mais et c'est bien
utile
pas sûr d'ailleurs que ça aille bien
mimétisme provincial j'aime vos
collections provincial allez quatrième
thème de ce match messieurs le passeport
vaccinale les discussions sont toujours
sur la table de la commission européenne
c'est la grèce qui a lancé l'idée
mi-janvier pour sauver son industrie
touristique cela pose d'énormes
questions juridiques puisqu'on parle là
d' atteintes éventuelles à la liberté de
circulation des citoyens européens
écoutez ce qu'en disait geoffroy roux de
bézieux c'était il ya quelques jours sur
france inter et montrent une importance
moi je trouve le mot passeport vaccinale
effectivement on se dit passeport
atteinte aux libertés etc
le carnet vaccinal ça existe quand vous
mettez vos enfants à la crèche
aujourd'hui en france il faut montrer le
carnet avec celle quand vous allez en
guyane il faut montrer que vous êtes
vacciné contre la fièvre jaune
ça n'est pas une atteinte à la liberté
c'est tout simplement protéger les
autres paul cassia les comparaisons sont
elles pertinentes
non alors dire que ce n'est pas une
atteinte aux libertés s'est radicalement
faux puisque c'est une atteinte frontale
à la liberté de ne pas se faire vacciner
la liberté personnelle donc c'est une
atteinte à leur consentement aux soins
que d'obliger soit directement soit
indirectement des individus à se faire
vacciner
mais cette atteinte elle n'est pas
nécessairement irrégulière il y à des
atteintes aux libertés qui sont
régulières on les vit tous les jours par
exemple aujourd'hui comme depuis un mois
il ya un couvre feu jusqu'à 18h site une
atteinte à nos libertés
elle n'est pas irrégulière donc là en la
matière il ya une balance à faire entre
la les avantages des vaccins et les
inconvénients qu'ils portent sur nos
notre notre libérer l'espace
on ne force pas à nous faire vacciner on
nous empêche de circuler si nous nous
sommes allés signer à lorient c'est
comme une j'imagine une nuance juridique
ni c'est une nuance on ne nous oblige
pas dirait on ne vous obligera sans
doute pas directement nous faire
vacciner mais en revanche il y aura tant
de contraintes qui seront apportés aux
personnes qui ne sont pas vaccinés que
indirectement sera très incités à se
faire vacciner et je crois qu'il n'y
aura pas de d'inconstitutionnalité à cet
égard 5e surtout qu'il y aura
vraisemblablement des politiques
sanitaires menées par d'autres pays les
rires of wire qui contraindront à
détenir ce carnet vaccinal je préfère en
effet cela à passeport pour pénétrer sur
le territoire dont il y aura non
seulement la contrainte interne et il y
aura la contrainte externe qui pèsera
certainement très lourd aussi donc c'est
évident qu'il y a derrière cela une
incitation au vaccin forte ça c'est une
c'est une évidence
ça vous gêne en tant que juriste ou pas
en défense ça vous gêne en tant que
manger danseurs délibérant j'éprouve axe
1 donc sur ce point je hais je pense que
je pense que toute l'histoire de la sens
de la santé publique et puis de la santé
moderne et elle est lié au vaccin depuis
génère la variole puis on passe les
anglais les premiers je crois qu
incontestablement une grande partie de
l'humanité n'aurait jamais survécu s'il
n'y avait pas eu les vaccins donc je ne
suis pas anti vaccins ce plan s'il y un
passeur et il a le droit même par contre
les sociétés ont le droit à leur tour de
fixer les limites et les libertés de
circulation des personnes non vaccinées
si elle estime qu on met les autres en
danger car c'est bien ça je ne suis pas
vacciné je prends un risque pour moi je
suis parfaitement le droit mais je peux
mettre les autres en danger chara cette
fois ci c'est le criminaliste qui parle
je sa mise en danger délibérée non parce
qu'il n'ya pas de mal vie dans sa mise
en danger de la vie d'autrui donc pour
protéger la vie d'autrui mais les états
ou non d'anor public destine qu'il faut
limiter la liberté de circulation c'est
une atteinte paul cassia raison est-ce
que c'est à zend et proportionnée
l'objectif qui est la préservation
possible de vie j'aurais tendance à dire
oui parce qu'on parle aussi d'enjeux
économiques alors en une minute si vous
pouvez nous répond mais là on oppose du
coup le droit à l'économie mais c'est à
dire que voilà il y a deux plateaux dans
la balance on vous dit d'à côté vous
faites vacciner et de l'autre ben si
vous ne vous faites pas vacciner vous
vous serez sous couvre-feu vous ne
pourrez plus aller au restaurant vous ne
pourrez plus à l'est dans les remontées
mécaniques vous ne pourrez plus à l'est
dans les spectacles donc voilà ce que
vous avez vous avez ce non choix donc la
vaccination elle peut être acceptée je
crois que si on démontre à la fois que
les vaccins sont efficaces ce qu'on ne
sait pas encore jusqu'à présent sur et
qui n'ont pas d'effet si on al'exemple
israéliens qui nous montre qu'il ya une
baisse des contaminations et les cas
graves
d'accord mais à tendance soyons quand
même prudent il faut avoir un minimum de
recul moi je ne suis pas je n'y connais
rien et me légiste voilà mais il faut
quand même que les principes de
nécessité et de proportionnalité soit
respecté ce qui demande d'avoir à une
étude d'impact c'est à dire un rendu de
résultats sur le terrain et on
s'arrêtera là merci merci à tous les
deux encore une fois d'avoir participé à
ce match passionnant merci beaucoup fin
de cette émission on se retrouve demain
à 18 heures et à 22h30 comme tous les
jours et puis comme tous les jours aussi
vous avez rendez vous avec bonjour chez
vous 17h30 au rayonnement de chimie
recevra notamment emmanuelle wargon
ministre délégué chargé du logement
je vous souhaite une excellente soirée
sur public sénat
[Musique]
revoir ce coup